c'était il ya un peu plus d'un an dans
la nuit du 23 au 24 mai 2019
philippe ferrière alors sous l'emprise
de l'alcool et de la cocaïne se rend
devant le domicile de sa compagne karen
lévis cette dernière le décrit malgré
ses problèmes d'addiction comme un homme
non violent elle craint en revanche
qu'il ne se blesse lui-même ou qu'ils ne
provoquent un accident en guidon de sa
moto
ce soir là elle décide donc d'appeler la
police pour le calmer mais
l'intervention tourne mal excité en
sueur selon les agents il reste gérable
jusqu'à un changement de comportement
lorsque lui et annoncé son
interpellation et des coûts sont alors
portés au moniteur d'auto école est l'un
des trois policiers réalisent une clé
d'étranglement amenant l'individu de 36
ans au sol les minutes passent et
l'homme reste immobile menotté face
contre terre
karen mère de son fils de 7 ans assiste
tétanisé à la scène et philippe donc été
posée sur la le coffre de la voiture est
bien savourer ce moment là qu'ils se qui
se prend des coups de partout près de la
tête et mon on habite ici donc on voit
ce qui se passe par les fraises on ouvre
les volets parce qu on entend crier
finit par fibre refusez donc de mettre
les menottes et quand on a vu qu'ils se
faisait taper dessus et qu'on lui a dit
par la fenêtre laisse-toi faire il a
levé les mains c'est mon fils aîné qui
est descendue auprès de me laver les
mains
il s'est retourné il a dit laissez moi
dire au revoir à ma faim
ils les ont pas laissés et non pas et
c'est fini vous le dire au revoir et il
est encore pris des coups fumeux
philippe les a poussés comme pour leur
dire qu'il respirait plus parce qu'il
prenait des coups de partout donc les a
poussés pour prendre de l'air et c'est
ça lui a été fatal puisque l'un des
policiers est tombé
et la suite ça a été dramatique est un
acquis du passé
enfin le bras autour du cou pendant
qu'il ya un vote qui me met matraque sur
la cuisse et lots que tu portes un coup
au plexus donc à ce moment là philippe
s'écoulant je revois la scène je
continuais proche du pentagone
j'aurais pas dû les laisser taper mais
malheureusement l'éducation a fait que
mal je ne réponds pas la police et jeu
surtout pas les contrarier
puisque normalement ils sont censés
d'être formés et en devoirs c'est bien
protégés j'ai pas imaginer deux minutes
que la police tuait les secours
finalement appelé à la rescousse tentent
de le réanimer mais il est déjà trop
tard
philippe ferrières et déclaré mort à
2h30 du matin les conclusions de
l'autopsié sont sans appel
le décès est due à une asphyxie
mécanique par compression cervicales
associé à un traumatisme cranio facial
plus d'un an après le drame une marche
blanche a été organisée en hommage à
philippe ferrières les personnes qui ont
pris part à l'événement réclame justice
je suis en colère quand en colère envers
l'institution policière parce que on a
besoin d'une police en france parce que
malheureusement la violence engrange la
violence il ya de plus en plus de
violences en france la police
aujourd'hui elle est dépassée par cette
violence très qui me choque c'est qu'à
l'origine et au carel
canaliser pour le calmer ce qui n'était
pas en état de reprendre la route et
qu'au final
posséder une histoire quelque peu
oubliée qui rappelle à certains égards
la sphère cédric joue via décédé des
suites d'une interpellation agitée au
mois de janvier dernier